Hello everyone.
I can't, I'm so tired, can't even raise my voice.
I'm so like I I thought the loop would give me more time to
wake up.
I did not win the nap.
Gotcha.
But then some of you guys were like Why were you napping?
Okay.
I'm gonna see if I have the energy to tell this story, guys.
I'm gonna...
Yeah, Ben, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, I'm gonna...
Let me see if I have the energy to tell this story,
everyone.
So...
and morning meme where it's like all right quick in and out
we'll be done well it's gonna be a quick in and out it'll be
done so soon it'll be done fast so i i thought of that plan
it's gonna be a 20 minute adventure let's go in and out 20
minute adventure So, I was that confident.
I was in America for one day.
I can't say what yet.
My plan.
My plan was to be to fly to America for like one day on
Sunday.
and then i was like i'm gonna come back on monday i brought
dad with me along too it's gonna be quick in and out it's
like i was like boom boom and then monday i fly back it's
tuesday today
it's tuesday
okay um okay so there was a lot of problems with this idea
there's a lot of problems with this plan i had well it was
barely a plan it was it was barely a plan the whole idea was
a problem I some can say that some can say that so oh yeah
okay is the BGM too loud because I'm not speaking in a
louder volume than this right now I'm I'm not speaking in a
louder volume really tired
okay oh the chat's dead just like me right now that's how i
feel on the inside okay so um uh anyway sorry i just need to
gather my thoughts here let me fix chat real quick also
So, okay.
Oh, okay.
So, that was my plan.
Quick in and out.
This is the first time Dad has ever traveled overseas, by
the way.
I thought I had it all down.
I was like, boom.
And then back on Monday.
So the plan didn't work out as I thought it would.
Drive on Sunday.
But I was like, fly on Sunday.
Sunday leave on Monday so my plan was for sorry over
countries this is the first time that has flew outside of
Canada so um so there is a sea it's not in between us but
like there is a sea anyway so um going there was fine it was
coming out that was harder So, I tried to, so I was sort of
like not in the city, like where I was like staying at.
I was not in the city and I didn't realize how bad the Uri
situation was going to be when you're not in the city
because I've always been in the city.
So, I didn't realize, like, because I never experienced that
before.
So, I was like, that's all right.
I'll just schedule an Uber, because, like, if it's pretty
bad, like, I thought I was so smart.
I was like, I'm going to schedule an Uber, because the
airport is an hour away.
So, where I was staying at, for this thing, I have to do.
do.
And I was just like, all right, I'll just schedule an Uber
at this time.
It was very early in the morning.
It was very, very early in the morning for this flight
because I was like, I got to come back on Monday so I can do
work stuff.
And then that didn't work out.
I thought this plan was solid.
I scheduled it like five to six hours in advance and I was
like I'm so smart even though I live so far from the city
and the airport right now I have a scheduled uber so by the
time so like so I it's all right they know that they're
gonna come and then I got an scheduled oh i woke up early
saw the time i was like one hour before the uber was
supposed to come they were like this guy's taken your order
and he's gonna arrive at this time i was like sweet he never
came he he never came guys he can't he cancelled my i didn't
even realize this was possible.
He canceled my schedule.
I scheduled this five hours in advance and this guy canceled
my scheduled order like almost an hour before he was
supposed to pick me up.
So I was like, that's all right surely I'll get another uber
then I'll arrive and the thing is I need to be there early
because I brought dad along with me so there's a whole
process of of it because you got checking the dog too and so
and I was like and it's the airport Port was almost an hour
away as well.
So I was like, that's all right.
Surely.
And it was also the only direct flight of that day.
So like I didn't have to take any transfers.
Because I really did not want to take a transfer.
Especially if I died with me.
So.
so that obviously this plan that I had didn't go out that
well because it's Tuesday today my plan was supposed to be
Monday I come back anyway it hit the hour I was supposed to
leave I still had no uber and then like at at that time I
Finally, I was just like, this is not going to work.
I'm going to, I won't be able to, like, I won't be able to,
like, check in.
Because they, the thing in international flights is that
they close the check-in table an hour before the boarding.
So I was just, like, freaking out.
Freaking out.
Because I was like, I can't even find a car.
It had to take me to the airport.
And then finally, somebody picked me up.
But there's like, we're coming in 30 minutes.
And I can't risk that anymore.
I can't ask.
It's just like, what do you mean in 30 minutes?
You're already, I scheduled it over.
So, I had to call and I had to call and reschedule my flight
back.
And then I was thinking, I was thinking, okay, I really
don't want to do a transfer.
But there was unfortunately no direct flights on Tuesday,
which was...
which will be foreshadowing what is to come today and why I
am not okay today.
So, so I had to call my, I'm not going to, I'm not going to
give the name of the airline as well.
Not because I, I am a kind person because I don't want to
get doxxed with the airline.
that I was with.
But fuck this particular airline.
Fuck this.
Because like, I could have, I realized after everything that
happened, I could have not went with this airline.
But they were like, this is the, we don't have any more
flights for today, which was Monday.
So you have to take another flight on Tuesday.
And then And, and, but then, I looked up Google, there were
lots of transfer flight, it was just transfer, I had to do a
transfer flight, I had to do a transfer flight, and then so,
I, oh my God, the layover was so bad, but like, remember,
that's, that's on Tuesday, I'll tell Tuesday soon, and then
I looked up, and I was like, oh, there are all these other
flights, there are all these other flights, But I might as
well go on the same airline.
I might have gone on the same airline.
Well, part of city.
There was no way I was coming back on a...
I will say I was on the East Coast.
Fuck East Coast, but I'm sorry.
I don't want to go.
I was like, I'm not coming back to the East Coast after.
I don't think I'm bust.
Take me back to West Coast.
Guys, I don't think...
I can't find us.
I think there was no other way.
I'm sorry.
There's no...
I wish there was another way to get home.
I wish...
Okay.
All my problems came from the east side
Anyway, I had to come back on I wanted to come back on
Monday All right, okay Okay, I thought this was a brilliant
plan.
I thought it was a okay anyway, but I didn't want to pay
extra I was being a little cheap there but like you don't
understand it was an hour away the airport was an hour away
and it was i was like the uber to the airport cost a hundred
dollars Canadian I think no no it was a mirror I think it
was a mirror I don't remember I don't know I was just like I
didn't want to look at it anymore
I was like, I'll just keep with the same airline because I
didn't want to pay extra because, like, I couldn't get a
refund.
Obviously, I can change the date.
I was still going to be charged for changing the date, but
then it was still cheaper than me canceling and losing that
flight, like, losing the money and then booking another
flight.
So, so I was just like, I'll stay with the airline and then
just fly the other flight they've had left the next day like
I took that risk because I was just like or I was like I
could fly today or I take the risk and fly the next day so
at least I don't lose the money I paid for this flight in
particular then came Tuesday that's where all the problems
came So remember when I told you I scheduled an Uber?
So this time, I scheduled it even earlier.
I scheduled it on Monday.
So it'll be like, I'll give a random time.
I'll give a tempered.
What if it was like, it's like what's seven?
Okay, so I scheduled, just hypothetically, okay, not
hypothetically, but like, I won't say the exact time because
I just got back.
So I scheduled an Uber.
Imagine it be like 7 p.m.
That's the Uber I scheduled.
But that like, what if that's like early in the morning?
But that was not the exact time.
Seven, it wasn't the time.
But like, it was 7 p.m.
And then at 6.50, I was like, I should take dad for a walk.
So he could pee and poop.
Because it's going to be a while.
A while, a long flight with the transfer.
because there was a fucking transfer.
This is going to be a long flight.
So he has to pee and poop as close as he can to the flight
time.
And I looked at my Uber app and the guy still took my
scheduled Uber.
He took my scheduled Uber for like, a while so I was very
confident and it was 10 minutes 10 minutes before before he
was supposed to arrive so I took that for a very quick pee
and poop came back to where I was supposed to be picked up
and I realized the car was still not here
And then I looked at my app.
And then I was like, this is not the same guy that picked up
my...
This is not the same guy that picked up my scheduled Uber.
By the way, I scheduled it earlier too.
Because last time I was like, I was cutting it way too close
with all this stuff that was happening.
So I gave myself one extra hour early.
too i gave myself an additional hour early so i was so
confused and then i was like why did it say picked me up so
this guy canceled on my uber five minutes before he was
supposed to pick me up and then but luckily thank god
another guy picked up my uber but then he messaged me
because i looked at my uber app and it was like pick you
know person has been picked up they're now heading towards
the airport and they messaged me and was like i don't know
what's going on but your address is not showing up and then
i was like it says you picked me up but you did not pick me
up so apparently the guy accidentally double tapped on the
pickup order and then accidentally confirmed up while he was
heading towards me and then so the address did not show up
for him anymore because he accidentally confirmed pickup
while he was heading towards me and then so i had to give
him the new ad like give him the address and he's like i'll
be there in 15 minutes luckily luckily this time i made
luckily luckily uh
luckily i was a lot earlier this time so like i had leeway
with him being late picking me up i i i had i had leeway at
this time
so so you're thinking oh that's the end that's not the end
of the story okay we got there we got there and um well it
had to be pet friendly too because I brought dad along this
crazy journey on me with me and I checked in I should have
knew something was going on I should have known like as we
progress it was gonna get worse and worse i thought that's
the last i was like i thought that was like the last of all
of this um also it's not the reason why there's no schedule
it's because i'm waiting for it okay it's like partially the
reason why because i was like worried i was gonna be stuck
in america i was kidding a little worried but also i'm still
waiting on confirmation on what the fuck is going on on
Thursday, which is the big announcement.
And this is also why I'm so fucking exhausted, too.
I'm waiting on confirmation on Thursday.
Like, I don't know what time I can even, like, I don't even
know, I have to coordinate.
I don't know what time the announcement's gonna pop out.
So I'm still waiting on confirmation.
Okay, anyway.
Okay, tomorrow.
Also, Marvel already know the drill but it's on twitch you
guys know the drill early access for rivals tomorrow on
twitch uh i believe it's 2 p.m psd so like it's already sort
of like a lot and everything also fight and i don't i won't
be streaming on fight fighting saturday as well because um
you'll find out why on thursday you'll find out that's why
it's like what's the point of making a schedule right now
like with all everything thing going on like so i i was
already missing because i was like i'll stream on monday
i'll stream on monday when i come back i can't even come
back on monday okay all right anyway sorry back to the story
so i checked in and then for those who don't know if you
travel with your pet you have to leave your pet at the
oversized baggage um at the oversized baggage thing and uh
so when you check in and then um some flights won't allow
you to I had to check in dad as a cargo because uh he's too
long like he's too long to get like the under the seat thing
like he's not gonna be happy and also I was in economy
because I was like in and out real quick
as cargo so like you have to be in the hard ass kennel case
and everything so all right so i knew something okay so like
there's already you know the trip was already the travel
part of it was not going so well but i thought it was almost
over like we're at i we're at the airport you know it's
almost over me and dad were here you just got one transfer
it's it's a long play but we just have one transfer and and
so the lady i thought she got everything stickered onto the
kennel and then i you know took me and the dog i traveled to
the oversized baggage area it's a long walk there and then
because I it's this is my first time like you know as an
adult traveling with with a pet and so I don't really know
the procedures so I got there and then the lady was like
where's the tag I was like what do you oh by the way when I
was walking over there I saw another person with the dog
carrier walking back and I was like oh I guess he forgot to
check in his dog I said that look at him Anyway, I found out
that guy was on the same flight as me Um And that was the
side That should have walked back as well Because Because
apparently The check-in lady Forgot to give me A baggage tag
For the dog So because The security lady in the oversized
baggage area was like where the fuck is the baggage tag and
I was like what do you mean it's all there and he's like no
you're missing the baggage tag to where like they scan so
that they know where to put your dot which flight to put
your dog in and I was like you mean all of these stickers
that they put on the fucking kennel none of it was the
baggage tag so anyway
that guy again because he got his tag he also did not get
his baggage tag for his dog as well because we were at both
on the same flight with the same check-in lady and she
forgot she forgot to do that for us so you think that's it
right Anyway, obviously, I had to ask a couple of questions.
Like, is my dog going to, since it's a transfer flight, is
my dog going to be transferred directly to the other flight
without me having to worry about anything?
Because when I got into America, that was the case.
So they were like, yes, you don't have to worry, but just
head to your connection flight.
Now this is what you also call foreshadowing.
This is also what you have to call foreshadowing.
I asked the right questions.
Anyway.
Anyway, very confident with the answers I was given.
I went to check in my dog.
And then, you know, boarded the plane.
And I thought that was it.
I got everything.
It's so early in the morning.
Oh, yeah.
Also, I wanted...
Like now that I look at it, I was like, at least it wasn't
as bad as everything else.
I went to grab breakfast.
It was so early.
I didn't eat food yet.
I went to grab breakfast.
Wanted an omelet.
The lady was like, sorry, we don't have omelets right now.
I was like, oh, that's all right.
I guess I'll have some chicken strips and guess I.
It was like breakfast.
but they didn't have all they didn't have the omelets for
some reason they have eggs I also got scrambled eggs on the
side because they at least they had scrambled eggs I don't
know I don't know what the fuck they don't have when it came
to like the omelet part they already have the egg part of
the omelet I don't know what ingredients they were fucking
missing but anyway I couldn't even get my fucking omelette.
It's so...
Anyway, I poured it to play.
It's got on my seat.
And you would think that was the end of the story.
So, behind me, we're two kids
and then you would I was just like one of the kids oh I
wrote this down I wrote this exact dialogue because I I know
her name but I won't talk to her name there's like
alright so she started kicking my my my
while we were waiting for the flight to take off she these
are kicking my chair and fucking playing with the the table
so it was like up down and then the mob obviously was not
controlling her very well and she would not stop talking she
would not talking she was like I won't can I take out my we
were we haven't taken off by the way we were all I'll take
up my sipa I'll take it out he's like no no okay I'm gonna
give her a little I won't dox that that child despite how
much how much I want to how much how much it's killing me me
to hold that inside right now.
like, morally knowing that's very wrong, but I don't care
about morals right now because she did not.
Because if she did it, why should I?
We'll call her.
I'm trying to think of a girl's name right now, but nobody
deserves to be her.
No one deserves that punishment.
Kids are so...
Okay, I'll call her Jane.
Little Jane.
Little fucking Jane.
She was like...
Okay.
I'm
I'm sad Can't take my seat belt off mommy Can I And then the
mom will be like no Jane You gotta keep it on till take out
And I wanna take it off And then she Her littler sister At
this point I was like I do not care If like iPads Rot this
girl's Brain please give her The fucking iPad so she can
watch Peppa Pig.
I don't fucking care.
Like, ma'am, you brought two toddlers on display.
What did you expect?
Give her the fucking iPad.
Anyway, it did not stop there.
It was like, little Jane, Lil Jade was like I can't I want
to go to the bathroom By the way Our plane hasn't even
fucking moved yet
She's like Can you hold it in Until the flights take off I
was like no No I need to go now I don't know if she was She
was threatening her or not because she wanted to fucking
take off her seatbelt or something i don't know if oh my i
don't know also by the way never mind there's two there to
the destination sorry a little segue i should have known i
forgot it was not smooth sailing heading to america i was
undergoing the worst turbulence i've ever encountered
getting that was the side that was the sasha turned back
that that was the the that was not the move i should have
made i should have canceled the trip i had experience
because and there the plot pilot was like oh sorry um the
turbulence is really bad today and uh and then it was so bad
like i never got air sick by the way i've never but i was
actually getting nauseous that was how bad the turbulence
was it was because i had to go to this transfer like this
transfer and apparently where i was at for my transfer
heading to my destination the turbulence is apparently
really bad because of the wind and so the guy so but then i
was thinking this was also by the way i don't usually i
would take the front seats like even if i take economy would
be the front but then i took the back seats because it might
i've never taken i never sat in the back before and I was
like look at all these empty seats in the back oh my god I
can recline my chair nobody there won't be someone sitting
in the middle because I took the window seat and I was like
there won't be someone sitting in the middle and I could
like have more space and then nobody's sitting behind me so
I can recline my chair I didn't know I didn't know I didn't
know I didn't know there was a reason why it's empty I
didn't know
apparently the back is where it most most you'll feel so
much movement you will feel majority of the movement you
take the seats in the back anyway but like i i thought it
was fine after the turbulence was over i thought it was fine
and but then it was not fine for this other guy little bit
to the front he was like one row one or two row in the front
in front of me and he had to sit behind me and they gave him
a garbage bag they gave him a garbage bag because
it was not okay like ma'am can you please recline your seat
back and i was like no this was all I wanted is all I had I
was like I might become a statistic any moment now but at
least I can recline my chair at least okay anyway anyway
anyway I the guy behind like he got the seat behind me and
then couldn't recline my chair anymore like let me have this
i could be got it because at any moment at least let me have
this what is your face thank you for the super chat thank
you anyway the guy behind me was not feeling i'm pretty sure
he was throwing up i'm pretty i put my headphones I didn't
know I wanted to hear any of this and he was like are you
okay he's like no and I was like bro they gave him a fucking
garbage bag they gave him a fucking I don't think he's okay
anyway anyway I've learned my lesson that I'll never sit in
the backs anywhere I was like Whoa, look at all these empty
seats.
So much room.
I can't recline my chair.
Anyway, back to the child.
Back to the child.
But she really did not want to buckle her seatbelt.
Like, she wanted to unbuckle her seatbelt.
I'm pretty sure she was bluffing.
I'm pretty sure she was black.
She was like, it was like a hostage situation with her and
her mom.
because she was like she talked there was more there there
was more um because she was threatening her mom that she was
gonna fucking piss her pants if she did not want to have her
belt buckle anyway so there was her literaler sister like
her like a little like i was just like why would you do this
to yourself why oh no like like i was i like why would you
do this to yourself and do this to others why would you
share this to everyone else on this like your life must real
your life must suck right now and like at this point like
you're like i you want to bring this grief to others on this
tiny ass Played.
Anyway, I wrote this interaction because I was like, oh my
god, I couldn't have okay.
So her little sister, her little sister, by the way, the
husband sat on the other row with none of the kids.
She had to sit with two of the children.
You would think it'd be 50-50 where they split.
up the children the husband gets one she gets what no she
gets two of them and two of them are behind me
that coward anyway
anyway anyway this is interaction i heard We'll call the
little or baby Doe.
Is Doe sleeping?
Or is Doe sleeping?
And then a mom was like, Doe is probably sleeping right now.
Doe, wake up!
Mom, don't wake her up, sweetie.
Please do not wake her up.
Please do not wake her up, Jane.
And then Jane would be like, Doe, wake up!
Wake
up!
Oh my god.
Actual menaces aside I've never had much like You know You
know I've never like Thought much About like Like I had I
had opinions on children Like more so neutral at some, but I
you're flying in a submarine at 30,000.
You lock your purified hatred of humanity.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But like I oh my god, if there were ever any dokey spawns,
like little dokey spawns, they would never get on a plane
until they are 10 years old.
I was, I don't care they're like I don't care they're never
touching a plane until they're 10 at least I don't because I
would have to put up with like oh my god oh my god until at
least 10 they would be like what if you have to travel when
you go on vacation i will get a babysitter and then leave
them with the her leave them with the babe i don't care i'm
taking my vacation you are not coming with me i do not care
i do not want to deal with this i you are gonna stay in the
exact same place for 10 years whether you have to move i'm
sorry You're going on a bus and I'm going on the plane
We're staying here Until we can fly We're never moving, I
guess We're only traveling When there is a car When it's
traveled When it's able to be traveled by car When you're
able to travel by car good you're lucky lucky you like you
can go on vacation but no no you are never going on a plane
until you're at least 10 you're that should be a rule every
parent should follow this rule this should be a legalized
law someone put this in the constitution i don't fucking
care like for the sake of the humanity this should be in the
constitution
I will fucking lobby for this to Congress like I don't care
you're like oh think of the kid think of the kids do you
think this kid want to be on the plane because my spirit is
being on that plane right now that child did not want to be
in this plane this child did not want to be on this I am
thinking about this kid And none of us wants this kid on
this plane It should be a universal law I don't care if you
want to fucking go to Hawaii With your family The kid stays
at home You're not enjoying Hawaii with a fucking
two-year-old you're not enjoying that fucking vacation I
don't know okay anyway so so you think it's over after the
flight takes off then the littler littler child starts
crying the she started crying
and you would think it would stop you would think the mom
would you would think she would stop she cried for two hours
straight this littler baby cried for two hours right Behind
me.
Behind me.
Looking behind me.
The mom was like, please, please stop crying.
Please.
And just kept, I was looking back.
I was just side-eyeing.
I don't care.
I was side-eyeing at that point.
Looking back between my seats, the little gap between my
seat.
I was looking back.
She's like, please stop crying.
And then...
On the two hour mark.
On the two hour...
Mark.
The older child started crying too.
The...
The older child...
Because the baby kept crying so then that she I don't know
why she was crying I don't know why the older child was
crying, but she started crying too Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Okay Now I was staring It was a feedback.
I don't know what she has to cry about but
So it was around three plus hours of crying.
Three plus hours.
I recorded it.
Because I had internet and I was messaging up.
I was like, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't.
And they're like, oh, I can't be them.
I can't be I heard that and I was mad I was mad Wait let me
Okay Alright here You can hear it here you can hear it Two
hours Two hours Two hours of this Two hours of this Not even
three hours Three hours of this Three hours three hours
three hours of this but it was just it was it was two kids
it was two kids it was two children i i had my you don't
understand they were behind me they were behind me i had my
had music play my earphones have silencers like noise
cancellation it did not cancel it it did not cancel they're
crying i could still hear it crying they could still hear
they're crying
oh all right you think that's over right remember the
foreshadowing earlier the So, I got off the plane.
We finally landed.
The kids stopped crying, by the way.
The little, the other, the older baby was so fucking happy
and good lucky.
And I was just like, I hate you.
I, oh my God.
Why, why didn't he give you the iPad?
Why didn't they give you the iPad?
Oh my God.
I think she had ADHD.
I don't she's a child I she needs her brain to be around and
even more fucking turn on the cocoa melon for this child
like put on the cocoa melon like I don't care I do not care
anymore like
okay and Anyway, anyway, so I went, my track layover was
long.
It was like more than an hour layover.
So I just got to my connecting flight because I was told I
can just go to my connecting flight and then sat at a
restaurant and waited until I had to, until I had to board.
more than it was like almost two hours it was almost two
hours layover so anyway i got a call it was like i almost
didn't take this call because i was like why the fuck am i
getting a phone call but the the phone number came from the
place i was the airport like the the city i was in for this
transfer so i was so confused i was like i should take it
and then i took the call And they were like, you forgot your
dog.
And I was like, what do you mean?
Keep in mind, when I got this call, I had...
35 minutes still boarding.
You forgot your dog.
And I was so confused.
I was like, no, I didn't.
They're like, you're supposed to pick up your dog when you
land.
And I was like, what do you mean?
The lady at the airport that I flew from said that they
transferred my dog to my connecting flight.
So I went to my connecting flight.
And like, you have to leave and pick up your dog at the
customs.
And I was like, what?
They were like, you're not supposed to do that.
That's not protocol.
I'm surprised you were able to even go to your connecting
flight.
I was just like, oh.
How do I pick up my dog?
How do I pick him up?
You're like, you have to go to this gate right now and then
call the phone that you're there for your dog.
There's a phone there.
You have to pick up the phone call this customs officer that
you're here to pick your dog and you have to have your
paperwork ready.
I was like, what?
I was like, where is this exactly?
And then they're like, I'll say a random number.
It'll be like, it's at door 30.
I was like, where the fuck is door 30?
Where the fuck?
Please pick up your die.
I'm not thinking.
Where the fuck is Dorian 30?
What is
that?
Like, just leave.
Leave the gate.
Go to back.
Go to the arrivals area.
And find Dorian 30.
I was just like.
And you'll see a phone there.
And call the customs officer to come out.
and give you to pick up your dog.
Anyway, so I left the, I left the gate.
I left the gates area.
And then I went to like the desk and they're like, to be
like, do you know where door 30 is?
I have to pick up my dog.
Like the airline desk.
They're like, what are you doing here?
like why are you not at the baggage claim area to do this
you're supposed to go to the baggage claim area because i
was already out the gates you know i was like i didn't know
the lady who checked me in at the other airport told me i
didn't have to do anything i didn't they're like all right
you have to go to door 30.
i was like where's door 30 what is it like it's just go
straight and then you'll find door 30 if you just head to
this direction you'll eventually find door 30 there's like
there's like a phone there attached to the wall when you get
there and then you can call and then the custom officer will
show up
anyway i was like i think i wasn't okay like i thought i was
not okay and then the other lady was like I could take her
I'm heading there anyway thank God to that shout out to that
old nice old lady who walked me to door 30 because when she
walked me to door 30 I do not think I would have found door
30 by myself it was really that it was a small ass sign that
says that with the number 30 on it and the phone was like
deeper into the door so I would have had to go to the inside
the room to figure out that there was a fucking phone there
okay anyway I got worried now because now I was just like oh
man dad can't pee and poop in between the transfer and he
must be so thirsty right now it's also foreshadowing um
anyway i got there called picked up the the magical phone
where you automatically called the lady and i was like i'm
here to pick up my dog and they're like do you have your
paperwork and then i i don't know if i did but i said yes uh
i came went in just come inside the because the room i went
inside the room and then i saw the other guy remember that
other guy that we we like saw at the first airport and we
passed each other by because we're both we both got fucked
over by that check-in lady because she forgot our dog tag
our our travel tag well guess what else that what guess what
else he forgot about too like
he came back he was just what else that lady told him about
too.
So we both got told the wrong information.
Same guy with the same dog.
We both and he was like, yeah, she's, yeah, I got the call
that he said, I forgot my dog.
And I was like, me too.
We both got the call that we both We forgot our dogs.
We got...
It's not a two for two.
Anyway.
We had lost dog buddies.
So yeah, we came back.
It gave us the, I gave like the microchip information
because I don't know.
That was all the paperwork I had.
I gave my microchip info and they're like, okay.
And then I got worried because now I had 20 minutes till
boarding time.
I had 20 minutes till boarding time.
And I waited.
and I waited we both waited you was there longer than me by
the way we both waited
and then the officer yeah by the way the lady that took my
paperwork was like dressing a hoodie was just dressed in a
hoodie did not look like she worked here and then I just
gave her my dog back I did not question it and she was not
in uniform of anything whatsoever all she had was like I
guess like a walkie-talkie and hoodie on but I trust I was
like I trusted her to have my dog I no questions asked um
she just came out like are you the lady who caught her about
forgetting your dog and I was like well I didn't forget like
you know I still was trying to be like I didn't forget about
it like I was just trying to defend myself because it wasn't
my fault it wasn't my fault I was like well technically I'm
not I didn't forget about it I was told I was told that it
would take they would transfer my dog and it's like what are
you the late but did you did you not pick up your dog I was
like yeah I didn't pick up my dog I was like
um anyway i waited it was getting closer 15 minutes left no
it was like almost 15 minutes left and then the order the uh
the an officer in uniform the customs officer came out and
was like to the guy first are you the guy who forgot their
dog he's like yes and then he's like what dog is and he was
like Labrador like you're not the person and then you
pointed to me are you the one else like yes doxin is like
all right you come with me I was like you know we both we
both forgot our dogs so like they don't know which one like
and they're like do you have the rabies back like
certification I was like that's the paper work I needed.
That was when I realized that was the paperwork I needed.
Luckily, luckily I went on my email, searched up rabies, and
was able to provide him.
I was able to provide him.
Thank God.
I still have the digital record.
I love the rabies of the rabies Certificate but thank
fucking and it was not expired.
It was not expired.
I still have one more year I still have one more year Thank
God By the way the worst okay I had I was scared because the
doctor wrote my name Oh my god the certificate because he
was like between my microchip document and the microchip
document and the vaccine document and he was like okay it's
like it's like what if it's spelled it's like doke but
instead of spelling with a d they spelled it with a b or
some shit but it's also still pronounced doke so it was like
It was like dokey bird, but the D is spelled with a B But
it's so pronounced dokey so I was like yeah, they spelled my
name wrong on the document like it's just the first name
Though it's just the first name They're like mmm It was like
a thank God they got they think they're like hmm because
they're like what's the fuck why is it like they look
They're like why is the name?
different
anyway they approved the doc they approved it in the end
they proved it in the end and I was just like where do I I
have a I have a transfer where do I go and they're like just
find door number five Let's find door number five
Where is door number five?
Please Just say the left or right Anyway I they're like you
could take the dime now and leave and then I left and then I
had 15 minutes I had 10 minutes I had 10 minutes before my
boarding starts and I had to find door number five there
were some volunteer staff members I think it's like a
program where the elder they give like the elderly little
volunteer jackets and a little hat so that they can be like
productive and be active in society.
So I, cause like, it was like, I couldn't find any staff
members.
I need to find door number five.
Like I said, you couldn't poop and pee because I need to
take him to the oversized bag and check in.
Yeah, and then like, yeah, and I went to the nice old man
and I was like, do you know where I can check in my dog?
And he was like, check in your, I don't think I don't think
they briefed him on this.
I, I, he didn't, he did, he was not briefed on this matter
about pets because he was confused.
He was like, whoa, check in your dog.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
Never, I don't know about that.
They're like, what's your airline?
And I was like, this.
And then they're like, oh, just, oh, that airline check-in
desk is all the way over.
It's upstairs to the right.
You have to take, and I was just like, there's escalators
around me and there's escalators like what do you mean how
do i go upstairs because i have to because it's a kennel i
have to i have to push a car i can't do an escalator because
it's very heavy it's like i don't know where to and he's
like oh i know where the airline chicken desk is and then i
was like okay but i don't need the airline chicken desk i
need the oversized luggage baggage check it and he's like i
don't know where that is i was like what do you don't know
where that is um he's like well you can go to the airline
check-in which i know where it is and it's that way i'm just
like i don't need to check in with the airline i just need
to check in my dog to the at the oversized luggage baggage
area that does not matter which airline you're in you're
just you she's already checked in he's already he's already
checked in i just
Anyway, I was like, where's the elevator?
It's just like, oh, the elevator.
Just go to door 30.
It's next to door 30.
So thank God.
Thank God I knew where the elevator is.
Thank God I knew where.
It's like, oh, the elevator.
You know where door 30 is?
And thank God I did.
Thank God I did know where door 30 is.
Just that's where the elevator is.
The only elevator was that was close to me as like
There was no mass I did not see single map while I was
trying to figure out my location Oh,
my god Anyway
I was like trapped in my own little hell that they made
specifically for me and it's at the end it's just traveling
it's just
oh my god because by the way when they were telling me to go
to the airline check-in does he's like oh that's far and i
was like i have 10 minutes i
he's like oh that's far Went to the elevator.
Got to door 30.
Found the elevator.
Which, by the way, was not next to door 30.
You had to walk a little bit more after door 30.
At least that was like my waypoint.
Door 30 was like my fucking waypoint.
Like, if I knew where door 30 is, I can find the elevator.
And he was like, oh, it's next to it.
It was not next to it.
It's like a couple, like a two-minute walk forward.
And then I just, he said door five.
So then I just, I kept walking straight until I got the door
five.
So I kept walking straight until, luckily, the oversized
baggage area place saw me and the dog and then waved me to
wave me to them and was like oh yeah by the way okay there
was another way i've tried figured it out because they're
like because i noticed the gates so i'm just gonna do
something so it's like abcd like there's like gates abcdf
and then when i was in the connecting flight, my gate was
like letter, I'll do like a random thing, a letter B or
something.
It was letter B.
So that I saw on the sign, it was like, if you go this way,
you go A or B.
If you go the other way, it's CDF.
So I was like, I have to go B, right?
I was like, in my head, it has to be in the B direction.
Because by the way, the old grandpa never told me I have to
go left or right.
I just went with numbers to see the doors cutting lower and
then seeing seeing the thing being like well B has to be
where my airline is which means it's closer to my gate so
that might be where the baggage thing is too I walked in
that direction I was like I was on my own little quest with
just context clues context clues like no maps of where
anything is and then saw the door numbers getting lower and
low i saw the door numbers and i saw it getting lower and i
was like and i just walked i just walked until the oversized
baggage area lady weighed me down like that's for this right
and i was like
in via proximity via proximity and then i looked around i
saw the tanya sign oversized baggage oversized luggage oh my
god oh god yes i like it i made it i felt so sorry for dad
because he did not like he was just like please let me out
of this cage out and i was like me too Me too, Dad.
Me too.
He's just like, I'm free, right?
I was like, no.
They have to scan your cage because they have to figure out
there's a bomb in your cage.
Like, it's so...
They don't...
You have to be out of that cage.
Out of that kennel, Dad.
They need to figure out there's a bomb in there.
So he was able to poop or pee.
I felt so bad.
It was a long flight.
And then he hasn't pooped, peed, or had water.
And I couldn't get any of those things for him.
He's just like, it's over, right, mommy?
And I was like, it's time to go back in.
It's time to go back in.
And then, like, you know, like, you, I get to see him leave
this time.
Because usually, like, they would just take him and then
take him to another room.
But this time, the whole baggage thingy was in front of me.
so they open the gates and then you see it's like the toy
story of this movie where like you know the toy they're like
stole in the in the fucking belt conveyor belt he's like
being sucked into the conveyor belt and he's like looking at
me as he's getting slowly sucked in more and more by the
conveyor belt and he's like oh and i'm like i'm sorry
oh the gate slowly sending the gate the the gate The
shutters is closing down as he's slowly being moved forward.
And he's like, oh, oh, oh, oh, I was just like, I have five
minutes.
I have five minutes.
Anyway.
He was like just staring at me, looking into my eyes.
Looking into my eyes.
Traveling always a play, it's always a delay, cancellation,
worker strike, storm, unconscious unclear, new travel,
paperwork, payment, or million neppers, thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you.
Anyway, thank God right next to me was also the security,
the security, and it was dead, and it was like, nobody
lining up, so I got past that.
Thank a fucking guy Fuck this airport.
I can't dock the airport right now, but fuck this airport.
Anyway Thank God at least the security was dead and it was
not crowded and so when I went to the I Went to went and
went and went ran to my gate because like I got scared I I I
can't get scared.
That first thing, it was a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I always had not anything I care about checked.
I read horror stories where the airlines would be like, ooh,
survive, put your dog.
Oh, no, thank you, it was super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, I made it.
Luckily.
I made it just in time.
Where they, my zone was about, was all, like, I thought.
I'm pretty sure they were already boarding like zone four or
five or some shit because there's just nobody lining up
anymore Luckily, I made it.
I fucking I made it.
I made it.
I made it I'm on the plane.
I'm sitting down Nobody's sitting beside me because this
lady and I we both got the the outer seats So nobody wanted
to sit in the middle.
Thank fucking god.
I was so happy.
We have so much room There's me empty seat lady.
I got the window seat And I sat down.
It's all over.
I made it home.
It's all.
I'm heading home.
It's over.
There's no children next to me.
There's no children in the front.
There's no babies in the back.
It's fine.
Then the flight attendant came over to me and was like, oh,
miss, it says here that you have a, uh, you have a pet
that's supposed to be with you, right?
um in our in our uh pressurized uh pressurized cabin I was
like yes yes I do it's like oh I'm gonna get you the I'm
gonna get you the your ticket then because um they're
supposed to go down and then rip a ticket and then give it
to me to be like they're here and I was like all right and
then I think 10 minutes passed the lady comes back and she
was like Sorry Miss um we're still waiting for your dog is
still not here yet so we're just gonna be waiting for the
little bit until and then i can get your ticket i was like
that's no problem that's fine you know maybe he's still
getting security checked and a different lady came in and
was like what time did you put your dog through the
oversized luggage and i was like um 40 minutes ago
40 minutes ago.
They're like, we're trying to find your dog.
So he was missing.
He was...
He lost his...
I thought he was...
I thought he was in the gap.
What happened?
I didn't
know how to feel.
I felt so...
The thing is...
I felt so many emotions through...
It was a Tuesday.
And I've been feeling a lot of emotions on a Tuesday.
I...
At that point, I...
I think I was fully disassociated at that point because I
was like, I've already hit my lowest.
I didn't know what to feel anymore.
Anyway, and she's like, okay, it's just like exactly what
time did you put your dog through the oversized luggage
area?
I said, this time, they're like, okay, and walked away.
And then 10 more minutes passed.
We should have been...
We should have been flown out 20 minutes ago.
We're 20 minutes past our departure time.
We were...
We were 20 minutes past...
Another...
The lady came back and was like...
Um...
Can you like go...
Can you get up and go up front to talk to the agent for us?
So I had to get up.
Everyone saw me get up.
Everyone has been seated down for a while now.
Everyone knows it's me now.
Everyone knows I am the reason for the delay.
I...
It was her.
I had to do the walk and show.
shame through the aisle standing up, everyone knows now.
Everyone knows it's me.
Why were...
Oh yeah, I might have made some people Mr. Connecting
Flight.
That's true.
That's me.
I'm...
Boo.
I went to the front of the airplane, the gate, to like the
door, and then they were like, so we're trying to find your
dog right now.
We need to know exactly what happened.
How did you get your dog?
Did you get your dog through the customs or the baggage?
I was like, I got my dog through.
because like I don't know I don't know they interrogated me
it was like was like did you grab your dog during the
baggage she was like no I grabbed it during the customs
because and then I had to explain them there the the
check-in lady from the other from the other airport told me
I didn't have to take it I'd explain the whole thing I
didn't have to explain everything they're like they were the
connecting flight so I like and then I got called and I had
to go to the customs to and I had to leave the airport to
pick up my dog and then go all and then and then after
leaving the airport I had to I had to go back and recheck in
and everything and then they're like and I was at this time
they're like okay we're gonna try it we're gonna try and
find your dog we don't know where he is right now and I was
like what do you mean you don't know where he is did you put
him on plane where is he i mean where did you put him where
did he leave
how did you fucking lose him
he's like shipped to another plane we're so he's flying back
to america
Anyway, now I'm going to renew my password, noophobia
unlocked.
Lucero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, they're like, okay, that's enough information.
You can go back onto your seat now.
I did another walk of shame back to my seat.
I did another 15 minutes later.
By the way, there was sky, and I was like, to the to the
lady was like why is our flight taking so long to take off
and then the lady the the the guy who was like in the row
across from us was very mad and i was like oh thank god he
doesn't know it's me he doesn't know the walk in shame was
was because i'm the delay at least this guy doesn't know he
was very mad and then the lady the flight attendant was like
there's uh we're just missing one more luggage um and then
we're going to be taking off soon uh we're we're we're just
missing one more and then
and then finally the flight came back and gave me the little
tiny little red form the little tiny tag red tag because she
dad is finally on the plane and she ripped the red tag from
his kennel give it to me he's finally here Finally here
Oh my god He's like here's your Here's your tech He's on the
plane now How many more stories of you At airports do you
have I'm really I think I'll love her Thank you for the
super chat If I had a choice I would stop flying I I think
I'm But I don't have a choice I don't have to I will say for
the reason why I'll be gone on Friday and Saturdays because
I will be flying again And I do not have a choice in that
matter.
I you will find out on Thursday on Thursday You will know
Everything will be revealed on Thursday and I'll be back
again.
I and left me off of this Mr. Bone's wild ride.
Anyway.
You see, other people just have to deal with delays.
So, like, a flight being pushed the next day.
I wish that was my problem.
Anyway.
but anyway so he's finally on the plane we did it we did it
everybody we the adventure finally ends i was so tired i was
so i was so tired made it home i picked him up no obstacles
and then the one It was just the last, fuck you.
The God said one last, one last thing for the ride.
I managed to grab the cart that had defective wheel.
So it was like a little bumpy, like a little bumpy car.
It was like, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Dad, it was Dad's own little turbulence.
The turbulence never ended for him.
late.
He's like, I was, I couldn't grab another car.
I was already too late.
I was too far gone.
I, so dad's, dad was still experiencing the turbulence.
I think the wheel was dented or something.
Anyway, I finally made it, made it home.
And I, I, I, I fed him.
I, he, oh my God, he was so thirsty.
I had to refill.
I had to refill the dish twice.
He's like, I was like, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I gave him his walkies.
Oh my God, the poop was huge too.
He was fucking waiting for so a lot.
And then I passed out.
Fast note in bed and I was like, oh my god, the stream.
Oh my, because when I decided 7 p.m., that was before I was
on, that was, you know, before I was on the plane.
I was just waiting on the thumbnail.
The way I got the thumbnail, I just forwarded it to, I
forwarded it to my manager and then he just put up the
waiting room.
gonna go that bad i i thought i thought it would be fine
when i got there before the wild adventure truly began i i
was this close to cancel like no i wasn't this close but i
was like no i should i need a stream i need a stream i will
i i feel bad i need a stream oh my god but yes that was my
adventure.
I thought it'd be a quick in and out 20 minutes tops.
Little did I know.
Little adventure I was gonna have.
Little adventure I was gonna have that day.
Little did I know.
Rhythm be this that day.
but yeah anyway guys I think what I think we could just end
it here we could end the stream here I hope you guys enjoyed
that sounded like fun fudge that you listened for chat thank
you thank you I think I'm I'm Brett done with my therapy
session today you guys.
I thank you for letting me trauma dump my last two days.
Husky, oh my god, thank you for the 50 gift and chips.
I can't believe this was one story.
The story that never ended.
You thought it would be over, but it kept going on.
The story kept going on.
It can get worse.
There's no way it just keeps going.
It keeps on keep going.
But thank you, Husky, for the 15 gifted chips.
I think our time is up.
This therapy session is up, guys.
I'm going to go back to sleep now, guys.
did not get to sleep on the plane i wonder why anyway guys
i'm gonna go take a nap because i still have work to do as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around to get that blood flowing and if you stand for me and
to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye